Nobody tells people who are beginners,...
...and I really wish somebody told this to me,...
...that all of us who do creative work, you know, we get into it...
...and we get into it because we have good taste.
But it's like there's a gap.
That for the first couple of years that you're making stuff, what you're making isn't so good.
Okay, it's not that great.
It's trying to be good. It has ambition to be good but it's not quite that good.
But your taste, the thing that got you into the game, your taste is still killer.
And your taste is good enough that you can tell...
...what you're making is kind of a disappointment to you,...
...you know what I mean?
A lot of people never get past that phase and a lot of people at that point, they quit.
And the thing I would just like to say to you with all my heart...
...is that most everybody I know who does interesting creative work,...
...they went through a phase of years where they have really good taste.
And they could tell what they were making wasn't as good as they want it to be.
They knew it fell short.
It didn't have the special thing that we wanted it to have.
And the thing is, everybody goes through that.
And for you to go through it, if you're going through it right now,...
... if you're just getting out of that phase,...
...you've got to know it's totally normal. And the most important possible thing you can do...
...is do a lot of work.
Do a huge volume of work.
Put yourself on a deadline, so that every week or every month...
...you know you're going to finish one story.
Because it's only by actually going through a volume of work...
...that you are actually going to catch up and close that gap.
And the work you're making will be as good as your ambitions.
In my case, I took longer to figure out...
...how to do this than anybody I've ever met.
It takes a while. It's going to take you a while.
It's normal to take a while and you just have to fight your way through that.
Okay?